Sunday service in the key of purchase
collabora a sprawling monastic complex
of churches in the Ukrainian capital
and one of the holiest sites in Eastern
Orthodox Christianity
in the Orthodox tradition all believers
are united in Worship in the kingdom of
God
on Earth though things don't always work
out that way
be with me
two weeks back picturesque lavara was
raided by Ukraine's Security Service
looking for pro-russian activity other
Ukrainian churches Affiliated to the
Moscow patriarchate have been searched
too
all buddies responsible for ensuring
national security must intensify
measures to identify encounter the
subversive activities of Russian special
services in the religious environment of
Ukraine
Ukraine's Orthodox Church structure is
fractured traditionally it was
subordinate to Moscow but in 2019 an
independent Ukrainian Orthodox Church
was recognized by orthodoxy's highest
Authority in Istanbul and following
Russia's February Invasion the branch
still Affiliated to Russia renounced its
Moscow ties but suspicions of collusion
remain President zielinski says he wants
new legislation to safeguard Ukraine's
spiritual and dependence but there's a
growing danger of trampling Ukraine's
constitutional rights to Religious
Freedom
worshipers at pechersklavara insist
their loyal ukrainians and there's
nothing to hide here
so action is needed but it must be done
correctly there is no need to do these
searches what's the search for here
the security service behaved very
politely we have nothing against the
guys they did their job they came they
checked we show them everything
[Music]
who teaches at the lavara believes law
Breakers can be prosecuted without the
need for new legislation
the state must ensure equality by law
without resorting to Media spin but at
the same time the state has the right
and obligation to protect its
territorial Integrity if religious
organizations adopt a particular idea
that harms the state they must answer
according to the law
a priest from the lavara was arrested
for supposedly leading a pro-russian
chant alleged anti-ukrainian propaganda
was seized in other Church raids
in Wartime loyalties are constantly
questioned and Ukraine's leadership
wants priests to show which side they're
on Rory challenge Al Jazeera Kiev